I watched some reality TV and one of my
favorite shows is called bar rescue yeah
if you've seen this show I really yeah I
really like that program on bar rescue
an expert comes in and totally makes
over failing bars and nightclubs they're
not going well he comes in he kicks ass
and he fixes him up and makes him run
well the best thing about the show was
the host Jon Taffer
he's absolutely brutal to the bar owners
it's really fun take a clip look at this
clip from the show have you ever washed
your hands that's him being nice that's
yeah yeah that's his family's restaurant
well anyway CBS is always looking for
new programming and they're always
asking me to have any ideas so I thought
why not create a whole new reality show
with that guy Jon Taffer why not do it I
was so sure it was a winner I put all my
money into the project we shot 46
episodes I wanted to premiere the first
episode right here tonight see what you
think let's take a look Jon Taffer has
transformed of literally hundreds of
bars and nightclubs overnight but can he
do the same for small family operated
petting zoo
that's one quick
we forgot to ask this is a rescue the
Lafarge family has been running cuddly
critters for the last 50 years business
was booming until a swine flu epidemic
scared away most of their customers and
now the lafarge are getting desperate
looks like they need a petting zoo
rescued look at this a wonder it's a
ghost town this petting zoo is a
freaking dump the floor is literally
covered in straw and an owner sampling
his own cricket even for lots of seeing
zero eye contact from the animals it
looks like don't even wanna be I'm going
in and shutting this stuff down you're
running your petting zoo like a goddamn
zoo you're just trying to make the
children happy well you're making me
sick
and probably is this how you run a
family business we found animal crap on
the floor
that's not animal feces oh my bad
animals create feces
within just seconds this species can
create an unpleasant odor look I guess
did you do this did you do this [ __ ]
it I don't know which animal is
responsible for this crap but I want him
fired immediately go solve the [ __ ]
dilemma now Rebecca we're sorry you got
to go good now we can get to work
turning this piece of garbage into a
world-class editing zoo let's go to work
Barbara Kenny when I got here your
petting zoo is a complete disaster but
here's the good news
we created a petting zoo that not only
allows customers to peck farm animals we
encourage it are you ready to check out
your new petting zoo yes on a count of
three turn around
one two three holy moly whoo
[Music]
who you I never welcome to tease the zoo
has a whole new look that will be
familiar to customers plus all new
uniforms to the set and then buttons of
sophistication everywhere we absolutely
love it
[Music]
[Applause]
I love goats since Jon left business is
up over 70% teats is the petting zoo
destination dreams do come true
Gee's was shut down four minutes later
for serving alcohol without a license to
a horse
we thought realize
[Applause]
you